y
hace cuatro años inició una historia
para la medicina con una mesa de ping
pong y una billetera
mientras todavía me encontraba en el
sexto año de medicina
un día decidí ir a jugar tenis de mesa
como es de costumbre uno se quita la
billetera e se quite el celular se quita
todo pues dice que para ser más rápido
ese día dirigí mi mano hacia el bolsi me
di cuenta de que no tenía mi billetera
me preocupe estaba muy preocupado así
que decidí suspender el juego y me
dirigí hacia el parqueo pero como si el
destino me tomara de la mano ese día me
detuve y di a la distancia que estaba el
decano de medicina un gran mentor mío
y me dirigí hacia y dije voy a saludarlo
antes de irme los saludé y justo al lado
de él estaba un señor con una buena
sentada su espalda algo encorvada
te presento al licenciado daniel
martínez me dijo el decano yo lo saludé
y mientras nos tomábamos de la mano me
dijo el licenciado daniel cree que me
puede regalar dos minutos de su tiempo
yo le dije que sí pero pensando en la
billetera estaba preocupada todavía
él me empezó a contar su historia que
tenía 42 años que tenía un síndrome pero
no sabía cuál había visitado decenas de
médicos y especialistas
en distintas partes en distintos tiempos
de su vida pero no habían podido darle
una respuesta
me contó también que había sido víctima
de bullying durante su infancia y
durante su adolescencia tiempos que me
refirió fueron muy difíciles y que sólo
pudo superar gracias a su dios superior
y a su familia
en un instante había olvidado la
billetera su historia me cautivó me
intrigó
y yo le dije
licenciado nosotros vamos a hacer todo
lo posible por encontrar una respuesta
me fui a mi casa encontré la billetera
pero se había quedado conmigo el
misterio lo que no sabía ese día era que
en esos dos minutos se convertirían en
dos años de investigación científica así
que fui y se lo presenté a mi equipo de
investigación
un grupo de jóvenes tan curiosos y locos
como yo que trabajamos cada día para
intentar ayudar a la humanidad tanto
como se nos sea posible hicimos un
examen clínico completo una historia
clínica completa
comenzamos a hacer el análisis
como era una enfermedad genética
empezamos a hacer el estudio de acordes
en genética existen dos grandes grupos
de enfermedades de número y de
estructura las del número son aquellas
en donde hay una cantidad mayor o una
cantidad menor del número normal de
cromosomas que es de 46
y en problemas de estructura nos
referimos no a la cantidad sino a la
estructura a la composición de ese
cromosoma de los cromosomas dentro de
esa información genética que básicamente
nos construye así hicimos un cariotipo y
descartamos todas las enfermedades
numéricas tenía un cariotipo normal
luego procedemos con las colas
estructurales
pero debíamos ser sumamente precisos y
precisos ya que los exámenes genéticos
son muy costosos y para ponerlo en
perspectiva les voy a enseñar un
presupuesto real detallado del grupo de
investigación en ese momento
no teníamos nada nada nada más que la
voluntad y de hecho este proyecto se
llevó a cabo gracias a la buena voluntad
inherente de los seres humanos a
personas y organizaciones que nos
abrieron sus puertas no sólo a nosotros
sino la idea y el proyecto de ayudar a
alguien más de llevarle una respuesta a
alguien que por cuatro décadas había
estado buscando día tras día reto tras
reto
y así continuamos
haciendo los distintos análisis
logramos hacer una tomografía en donde
descubrimos una mandíbula pequeña tirada
hacia atrás
y hueso se extraen en el cráneo un
conducto auditivo externo
angosto también identificamos un grado
de sordera algo que es impresionante
dado que nuestro paciente se dedica a la
música y enseñarla
también presentaba alteraciones
cardíacas lo que se conoce en medicina
como un prolapso de la válvula mitral
una válvula de su corazón no cierra
adecuadamente dejando reflujo
presentaba vértebras con una angulación
anormal masas con intestino contenido
intestinal
de forma bilateral y también una
personalidad de tipo paranoide pero con
una con con un coeficiente intelectual
normal una vez analizando todos estos
datos durante más de un año luego
pensamos que que la lo que encajaba
mejor era síndrome de williams vive una
enfermedad rara
así que reunimos todos los datos tomamos
una muestra y la enviamos al centro de
genética de wynwood en carolina del sur
quienes nos apoyaron mucho
esperamos un tiempo y para nuestra
sorpresa cuando recibimos el resultado
negativo para el síndrome de williams
estamos devastados más de un año de
investigación de análisis noches de de
pelo con el grupo con el equipo de
investigación yo parecía mentalmente
inestable porque tenía fotografías del
paciente en un pizarrón de mi
apartamento con radiografías análisis de
análisis genéticos
y sintomatología y signos fue difícil
para nosotros pero nuestro paciente nos
dio la fuerza que necesitábamos en ese
en ese instante nos dijo adelante no se
detengan yo estoy anuente a seguir para
encontrar una respuesta y así lo hicimos
continuamos y así vinieron semanas y
semanas que se convirtieron en meses de
análisis y decidimos hacer un estudio de
genoma completo analizar toda la
información genética de nuestro paciente
y enviamos y debíamos enviar una muestra
al centro de genética de wynwood para
hacer ese análisis completo 2000 dólares
la prueba la mitad lo coste la
universidad católica de honduras la otra
mitad los estudiantes en la facultad de
medicina
y así lo enviamos
luego de un poco de paciencia un día fui
me senté en mi casa abrí la laptop y un
correo con el resultado de clic
no era síndrome de williams
pero esta vez
había un hallazgo
esto que ven en pantalla son las
coordenadas del cromosoma 7 de nuestro
paciente que están ausentes
una de lección y esto es lo que le da a
las manifestaciones clínicas a nuestro
paciente
hicimos una revisión de literatura y nos
dimos cuenta de que no existía en ningún
lado en el mundo descrito un síndrome
una manifestación es un conjunto de
manifestaciones clínicas asociados a
esta región genética y que no fuera
electro dactilar esto que ven en
pantalla
nuestro paciente no presentaba acto de
actividad pero tenía manifestaciones
intro micas algo que no estaba descrito
hasta el momento y así tuvimos el honor
de poder nombrarlo y de escribirlo y que
actualmente se conoce como síndrome de
ramos martínez ramos por mi apellido
martínez por el el apellido de nuestro
paciente en honor a él puedo hablar de
su identidad algo que es que no es
habitual porque generalmente se protege
mucho la anonimidad pero en este caso en
todo el proyecto el licenciado daniel
nos dijo que no quería esconder su
historia quería él él quiere que a
través de su experiencia se puedan
inspirar otros en el mundo que de
repente están pasando por lo mismo
es su sueño poder crear una fundación
que ayude a otras enfermedades a otros
pacientes que están cursando con
enfermedades de difícil diagnóstico
y poder ayudarlos a través del arte a
través de la música de toda esta
experiencia aprendí varias varios puntos
fundamentales primero las escuelas de
medicina no nos preparan para para
abordar estas enfermedades no existe en
el programa
s
es el proyecto de de enseñarles a los
médicos a poder identificar
estas estas enfermedades que actualmente
simplemente se conocen como enfermedades
raras son aproximadamente más de 7000
enfermedades que tardan en promedio 4 a
5 años para poder ser diagnosticados un
solo paciente esperando 4 ó 5 años para
ser diagnosticados mientras tanto pasan
con dolor sufrimiento sin tratamiento
el segundo punto son los patrones los
médicos trabajamos con patrones lo que
no conocemos no se diagnostica y se
deriva y ahí el problema otro dato de
las enfermedades raras es que
aproximadamente toma siete especialistas
un solo paciente viendo a siete
especialistas para alcanzar un
diagnóstico
no porque sean malos médicos sino porque
en las escuelas de medicina no se no se
prepara para afrontar estos estos retos
que representan ese grupo de siete mil
enfermedades y esto nos lleva al tercer
punto
la necesidad de crear una nueva
especialidad de la medicina que entrene
a los profesionales para identificar los
patrones de expresión de estas
enfermedades
enfermedades que se denominan raras pero
que es que solo solo
en la unión europea' afectan a más de 36
millones de personas
por ello cree este este término e
ideología del griego éticos que
significa especial y logía logos que
significa el estudio por tanto del
estudio de los casos especiales está
esta rama nueva rama de la medicina que
ya estamos creando y que la universidad
católica en la universidad católica de
honduras ya tenemos un grupo
multidisciplinario de especialistas
junto al equipo de investigación para
crear los algoritmos y protocolos que se
que se harán para enseñar a los nuevos
profesionales estas 7 mil enfermedades y
poder llegar a un diagnóstico más rápido
será el primer lugar en el mundo donde
se enseñe psicología y poder ayudar a
estos 36 millones de personas sólo en
sölden en la unión europea y así
millones más en cada continente
luego venimos con el problema del
tratamiento sólo el 3 por ciento sobre
el 3 por ciento de estas enfermedades
tienen un tratamiento efectivo los demás
están
las demás están olvidadas por los
proyectos de investigación de gobiernos
y empresas que como no las conocen no se
conocen mucho acerca de este campo de la
medicina y está olvidado en los
programas entonces no se invierte
para ponerlo en perspectiva de qué es lo
que estamos haciendo y cómo se va a
enseñar la ideología aquí en honduras
hace hace aproximadamente un año
recibimos otro paciente que tenía
manifestaciones clínicas del síndrome de
dawn había sido atendido en tres países
diferentes múltiples especialistas y no
se había llegado un diagnóstico los
estudios del genoma completo que
nosotros hicimos también los hicieron en
estos distintos lugares y habían salido
los resultados normal y le dijeron a los
padres tranquilos
todo está bien pero los padres tenían
esa angustia y sabían que algo no estaba
no estaba bien se acercaron a nosotros
cuando escucharon el caso del del
licenciado daniel y decidimos hacer algo
diferente no solo hacer estudio en
sangre donde se habían hecho todos los
anteriores sino hacer estudiar mucosa
bucal y así lo hicimos y ahí sí
obtuvimos un resultado en este caso sólo
el 15 por ciento de las células de este
paciente tenían síndrome de dawn algo
que se conoce como mosaicismo de
trisomía 21 y así analizando esto
podemos establecer un algoritmo a un
fenotipo es decir manifestaciones
evidentes se les realiza un estudio
genoma completo
si sale positivo pues ya obtenemos un
diagnóstico pero en haití colo he a casi
siempre las historias son un poquito
diferentes si sale negativo entonces
hacer un análisis de un tejido distinto
y de esta forma reducimos el tiempo del
diagnóstico de 4 o 5 años a unas cuantas
semanas tal vez un mes así como lo
hicimos con este paciente es un concepto
son conceptos que parecen sencillos pero
que no se encuentran en los programas de
medicina y esto hace que estos pacientes
sigan sufriendo el sufrimiento de
pacientes
con enfermedades psicológicas es el
mismo de cualquiera o de cualquier otro
no valen menos que un paciente con
diabetes sida o cáncer son personas
maravillosas vidas increíbles que
merecen ser escuchadas y no ser
olvidadas en el cajón de lo raro
por ello les digo en este momento débil
y vislumbrar la fitur el futuro tu tal
vez podría ser el próximo indicó logo
del mundo muchas gracias